welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the boys
gen V Episode 7 and episode titled sick
which sees the return of our favorite
boys head popper Victoria Newman and
answers a couple questions while raising
even more like who was on the other end
of Grace mallerie's phone call with the
news that genb has been renewed for
season 2 we are taking a look at all the
Easter eggs the details the links to the
larger boys universe and I'm going to
make some guesses on whether or not that
crazy scene was actually happening in
everyone's head also thanks to Opera GX
for sponsoring this video gen V is great
and one of the things we've enjoyed
about covering the show here on new
rockstars is how much extra content from
the world of genv is available online
particularly if you're using Opera GX
Opera GX is a super customizable browser
with roughly a bazillion mods that you
can install to customize your experience
or make your own we went with the Gen V
mod which includes everything from
wallpaper to background music keyboard
sounds and even sound effects for
closing tabs Opera GX also gives you
exclusive exclusive access to the vot
international social media site
dedicated to the world of the boys
letting you follow your favorite soups
from gen V and it's built right into the
sidebar which is super easy to customize
with whatever other social media sites
you want to visit it's accessible on the
sidebar on the left where you can also
find all other social media including
Discord twitch Twitter Tik Tok Instagram
and WhatsApp one click away and look we
know switching to a new browser can be a
pain but Opera GX has an import tool
that makes it super easy to import your
history bookmarks and cookies from
pretty much any browser you might need
to get exclusive gen B content from your
new favorite browser use the link in the
description below to download Opera GX
today we open in the woods with two
guards throwing a soup into a cell and
blocking him and with some others one of
them terrifyingly tells him try not to
breathe and we see the disgusting reason
why Dr cardosa succeeded in making the
virus contagious and poor Andy his first
coughing oozing guinea pig as the soup
pounds on the glass and begs to be let
out cardosa tells Shetty that the virus
spreads through direct contact with the
bodily fluids with which isn't good
enough for shett she wants it to be
airborne so it'll be even more
contagious for the first time cardosa
hesitates like dude you've been
experimenting on kids for years now and
just killed Betsy last episode and now
you might need to take a beat to
re-evaluate he threatens to tell vot
what they've been doing which confirms
that this whole thing has been shedo
Rogue while V likely knows the woods
exist and that soups are being
experimented on like they wore at Sage
Grove there is no way they'd want a
plague unleash that could kill all the
soups and essentially put them out of
business like a Stern mother scolding a
child shedy addresses cardosa by his
first name it's a little late in the day
to worry about what V wants Edison
interesting that he shares a name with
Thomas Edison who used teams of
researchers and scientists to come up
with his inventions but largely took
sole credit for them maybe this is a
hint that there were other people
involved with the creation of the virus
and that it's still a threat even if
cardosa is eliminated okay so big
spoiler warning here if you haven't read
the comics and planned to because I'm
about to tell you how they end skip to
this time if you don't want to know with
the help of Dr vogle bomb who we saw in
the boys he was the one who who
basically created homelander and raised
him in a lab butcher develops an
Airborne compound V Tech bomb it uses
missiles to Target soups and only soups
and would activate a substance in their
brains causing their heads to explode
taking all soups out at once long story
short huy finds out and stops butcher
before this happens gen V and the boys
Show creator Eric kryy has said that
these shows won't end like the comics
but this virus might be their way of
touching on that plot line and I think
this episode we get a little butcher
Cameo that proves that he now knows of
its existence Shetty threatens cardosa
with ually assur destruction I mean he's
just as culpable as she is for all of
this and then she gets a call from Kate
who hasn't been taking her meds and she
can now fully hear everyone's thoughts
she's like a deadly Suki stack house
from True Blood Shetty calls Kate
sweetheart and asks her if she's taken
her medication today always manipulating
that one Kate lies and says yes because
she doesn't want her to know what
they've all been up to as she walks
through the diner we see vot news
Network's Cameron Coleman on TV he's
also the host of seven on seven and we
saw him a lot in season three of the
boys and on the vot international
YouTube channel he's a right-wing pundit
who pulls his usual fearmongering here
broadcasting live from God you campus
police expect Mass protests leading up
to today's town hall with the
historically unpopular and phony
socialist scammer herself vice
presidential candidate Victoria Newman
Coleman goes on to say that Newman has
had campaign donations from George Soros
whose name has become a total dog
whistle in the real world for Fox News
hosts underneath the TV there are a
bunch of seven Funko Pops of homelander
black noir and starlight and both her
original outfit and her redesign there's
also a homelander action figure and a
bunch of American flags adoring the
diner walls Kate tells the group that
Shetty will be in the city all day so
she'll go to her house and wait for her
and then push her to tell them the truth
they still don't trust her though so
Andre decides to go with Kate to keep
her in check Marie and Jordan walk in
front of a wall covered in posters an ad
for Henderson brewing company with a
train that says you have to be fast to
catch the food truck before it's gone
Henderson is a real Canadian brewing
company and they have a blonde logger
called food truck there's also posters
for vot headphones that are ripoff of an
iPod ad various singer Newman political
signs these are covered in graffiti some
calling Newman a cop various spray
painted penises and then soup lives
matter a phrase that we first heard from
Blue Hawk in the boy season 3 when he
was trying to apologize to the black
community and on the far right there's
an ad for speeding bullet ale which is a
train spear there isn't a product that
this guy won't slap his name on Marie
and Jordan decide to use Jordan's ta key
card to look around shed's office while
she's in the city their plan is to get
proof about the woods and deliver it to
Victoria Newman while she's on campus
for the Town Hall in her dorm room Emma
tells Sam that she's going to take his
clothes to a soup with pyro powers to
burn them all and the evidence of his
puppet Massacre she's also going to grab
him some v a burger while she's out he
discovers her sex toy drawer which
includes a Starlight vibrator we first
saw this in season 3 of the boys when
Kimo killed a bunch of Russians she
actually threw it at a guy and lodged it
in his neck killing him it was awesome
Emma wears a gummy bear necklace that
we've seen her wear in previous episodes
gummy bears are small sweet versions of
real bears just like Emma is sweet and
can get small but also I do hope that we
get to see big Emma at least one more
time this season she makes Sam promise
that he'll stay in her room and talk to
no one until she gets back do not answer
the door no matter what stranger danger
stranger danger stranger danger stranger
danger was a phrase popularized in the
60s in the United States and England a
warn about the uptick and crimes against
kids and it's gone through several
iterations but it's still in use today
but what's interesting about stranger
danger is it's actually not the best
thing to tell kids because it makes kids
only fear strangers when statistically
most crimes against children are
committed by someone known to them and
in this case I think Sam is really the
danger to strangers considering what he
did to those guys in episode 5 Marie and
Jordan SE shed desk files and we see one
labeled Student Records GI and then form
labeled incident report Jordan tries
unsuccessfully to get into shed's
computer and I like the realism for once
that they didn't just try a couple of
combinations for a password and then
magically guess correctly but Marie
finds a file on transoceanic flight 37
that was a flight in season one of the
boys that was hijacked by terrorists
homelander and Ma tried to intervene but
things went South and homelander
inadvertently destroyed the plan's
controls and convince mave to just let
the plane crash since he wasn't strong
enough to save everyone and didn't want
any survivors to talk about what
happened all 123 people on board were
killed the public story behind the crash
is that terrorists took the plane down
before homelander and made got there but
may have had video proof of what exactly
went down used it a blackmail homelander
into leaving her in Starlight and a few
others alone the newspaper here has the
headline some word that ends in Y iing
for the missing of flight 037 then some
word then leaders come together then a
photo of wreckage in the water next to a
photo of a man that I assume was one of
the ones on that plane the next article
headline reads flight goes down in the
Atlantic one 23 on board 120 of those
were passengers three were the hijackers
underneath the headline is trans Oceanic
flight 037 ceased contact mid-flight and
then disappeared from radar in the
folder there's also an aerial shot of
the region where the plane went down
some photos of the wreckage and a
passenger manifest listing Lily Shetty
age 11 and Paul Shetty age 46 so our
guest last week about shetty's daughter
dying in a super related incident was
correct and we're not really celebrating
it she confirms later in the episode
that Paul is her husband we also see the
name Jessica Stein listed and that's
actually the name of first assistant art
director on the show The classified
photo labeled government exhibit shows
that homelander hit the controls with
his eye beams it's not totally clear
where Shetty got this file or this
information someone may have fed it to
her or maybe she just sensed that
something was off about the official
story and dug it up herself Marie and
Jordan are interrupted by a drunk
cardosa who Rambles to himself about the
virus while they hide under the desk he
also pees in shed's expensive booze
bottle which you know check off's pee
can't wait for that to get drunk by
someone down the line he drops a full on
shed's desk and we don't get to see
what's in it another mystery we see vot
tower on the city skyline near the
Empire State Building even though it's
set in Manhattan both the boys in genv
shooting Canada so that Tower is
actually based on Roy Thompson Hall in
Toronto they added some CG bits to make
it look like a skyscraper shedy meets up
with hey Grace mallerie from the boys
she was last seen in season 3 of that
show putting a knocked out soldier boy
back in captivity with the CIA Shetty
overplays her hand here she assumed that
mallerie would be on her side in this
given the fact that her grandkids were
murdered by Lamplighter but m Val points
out that killing all soups would be
genocide and a war crime and invokes
Billy butcher to try to convince her
that this is futile a man who works for
me one of your fellow countrymen
although I doubt you travel in the same
circles has the same rage it's so
consumed him that there's nothing left
trust me you don't want to go down that
path and speaking of butcher after
Shetty leaves looking concerned mallerie
asks someone on the phone if they heard
what just went down and then tells them
to keep a close eye on her I think she's
talking to butcher here he's the exact
person she'd UST something like this too
and making a dig at him while he's
listening in is very on brand for her
like she would use this as a teaching
moment for him I think that in the final
episode we could even get a small
butcher Cameo of him watching Shetty or
entering the woods or something Sam
entertains himself in Emma's room while
she's gone smelling her perfume bonding
with her gerbal David Caruso and even
looking through her underwear drawer
which hilariously has different sizes of
underwear for when she shrinks down
doesn't have any huge ones though since
she almost never goes big Sam Hears A
noise in the hallway and runs out to
investigate he finds a soup with ice
powers who made a luge and for once Sam
gets to just be a normal college kid he
goes for a sled down the hallway he
drinks the beer and he lets himself get
radicalized by Rufus the song we hear
playing during the shenanigans is Alex
Ley Spike the punch Rufus convinces Sam
to come to a party which turns out to be
Victoria Newman's town hall and Rufus is
wearing that red hat that says keep
America safe and you know from that he's
there to start some crap speaking of
starting some crap Cameron Coleman
interviews polarity who's supposed to
moderate the town hall later and we
learn that Andre hasn't spoken to his
dad since he found out that he knew
about the woods and did nothing to stop
what was happening and then we get this
freaky moment and it's a good thing that
someone as versatile and trustworthy as
you has stepped up to ask the tough
questions that superheroes and Real
Americans care
about notice that right after polarity
first Twitches you can hear the metal
around them in the studio rattling then
as he has a full-on seizure everything
metal in the studio starts crashing and
moving around this reminds me of
Professor X and Logan when he was
suffering from dementia that was causing
him to have uncontrolled telepathic
seizures that destroyed a lot of people
as the camera Falls over we get a vot
News Network please stand by card on
screen before it goes to a commercial
for vot pharmaceutical brand catheters a
classic commercial for 24/7 news
networks Andre takes off to find his dad
leaving Kate alone at ched's house Emma
returns to find the hallway wet from the
melted ice loue and Sam is gone which is
a problem considering he hasn't been
freeing around people in probably like
10 years or something she knocks on
Maverick's door to see if he's seen Sam
and Maverick and the alpaka Sloan are
into some kinky sex stuff again
seriously I need to spin-off about the
two of them and I need to know what
Sloan's deal is is she a soup who turns
into an alpaca some of the time is she
an alpaca all the time I need answers in
the ambulance polarity seizes again
causing the walls to start caving in
this is such a cool sequence as Andre
tries to balance out what his dad is
doing using his own powers and the poor
EMT just keeps getting hit by all kinds
of stuff flying around the ambulance is
actually a global Wellness Services
vehicle so they're probably taking
polarity directly to pot Tower because
honestly a normal hospital will probably
have no clue what to do with them Pro
and anti Victorian Newman protesters
convene on the quad holding signs that
say things like coexist stop the super
haate soups for singer inside the town
hall Coleman has taken over moderating
duties for polarity and he grills Newman
on her stance on soup rights and the
murder homelander committed at the end
of the boy season 3 so remember Newman
herself is a soup but only a handful of
people know that because she was adopted
by Stan Edgar from Red River after her
powers manifested and she killed her
parents accidentally Edgar planted her
in the government and kept their
relationship secret so that he could use
her for vot's plan she be trayed him and
got him Ed as vot CEO so as half the
crowd of soup students turns on her and
Coleman accuses her of persecu e soups
who he refers to as a minority
population she remains cool as a
cucumber always in control outside
Jordan causes a distraction so that
Marie can get close to Newman they do
this by sucker punching Justine who
totally deserves it after what she did
to Emma earlier the season spilling her
secrets for influencer clout Justine's
jaw dislocates and then immediately sets
back into place which is the first time
we see her use her powers a brawl breaks
out and Justine's friend with tail films
Jordan who she says is attacking her own
kind security goes over to break it up
and I hope these guys use more than just
night sticks because otherwise they're
going to going to be in some trouble
inside the town hall the Q&A portion of
the event devolves into a frenzy we see
some more signs in the audience one that
reads Heroes United another that Echoes
earlier graffiti we saw outside saying
Newman is a cop and since Newman is a
vice presidential candidate it kind of
Echoes some of the protesters against
Kamala Harris poting out her prosecutor
passed because despite her liberal
record she did put people in jail
because that's what a prosecutor's job
is there's another sign that reads
supers keep you safe another sign that
reads human silence equals violence
Rufus shouts out that humans aren't
their peers and the soup with the ice
power shouts soup lives matter Coleman
presses Newman to State whether soups
have human rights which she says they do
but then the soup girl from the hallway
earlier lights up her eyes homelander
style like she wants to laser slice
Newman in half and then things get a
little too real when this happens will
not control us you will not control us
I'm going to guess that Rufus is going
to stop off at the local Walmart or Pier
One after this to pick up some polo
shirts and tiki torches Coleman is
enjoying the chaos since he knows it's
going to be good for ratings one
audience member puts a hand on This
Woman's shoulder shoulder and she
Banshee shouts at him blasting him back
then a guy wearing a homelander shirt
uses laser vision to slice the flag in
half and that's when security ushers
Newman off stage where Marie is waiting
for her Newman agrees to go somewhere so
they can speak in private outside Emma
and Jordan finds Sam who sad to leave
his new soup supremacist buddies behind
seriously dude you've been out of the
woods and among people for 5 minutes and
you immediately fall in with the wrong
crowd what would television's Jason
Ritter think Shetty returns home to find
Kate who she calls darling again using
these familiar comfortable Terms of
Endearment like a mother might use with
her daughter but Kate is spoiling for a
fight and doesn't let her get away with
it this time Kate says that the meds
Shetty had her on weren't helping her
they were just clouding her the Kate
we've seen all season has been pretty
damn powerful so I can only imagine how
strong she's going to be once the meds
are fully out of her system Shetty tells
Kate that it's almost time to leave this
place and this whole exchange has such a
strange surreal feel to it she says that
both she and Kate are leaving because
she loves her like a daughter and she
wants to keep her safe unlike earlier
when we heard what Kate was hearing when
she read people's thoughts we don't hear
shed's thoughts here so we have no idea
who's playing who somehow I feel like
you are truly mine and I love
[Music]
you you're telling the truth notice the
look of relief on shed's face she tells
Kate she just needs her to do one last
push for her and then she'll never be
alone again Kate lays her head on her
lap like a little girl and Shetty again
looks overcome with relief but I have a
theory about this whole EX change a
little later then we get a huge reveal
not only is Victoria Newman Marie's
benefactor she has the same exact blood
control powers that Marie does so far
we've only seen Newman POP heads or
other body parts but it wasn't clear how
she was doing it so when she slices her
palm and controls the blood that comes
out it's super interesting it means that
at some point down the line Marie will
be able to do what Newman does Newman
also teaches Marie how to see the v in
her bloodstream and remember I theorize
that Marie might actually be able to
depower a suit by locating the V and
burning it out of their blood that means
that Newman can identify other soups we
get this little tongue and cheek nod
about what Newman can do you know what
we'll hide out in the green room until
it all blows over out there otherwise I
think they might take off my head take
off my head in a green room there are
dawn of the seven posters with queen
mave and a train both of course alumni
of gulin University another whiskey
Sunrise poster and a translucent poster
for a translucent invisible force 2 with
the tagline you can't kill what you
can't see H you totally can I mean do we
forget season
one the two women over the meals they
were served during their time at Red
River where they both grew up and Marie
and Trust Newman with the information
about the woods and the virus Newman
seems unconcerned and says she'll handle
it and we know what that means she also
gives Marie this two path speech and
seals it by invoking her sister's name
Marie Maro guardian of gulin is
marketing okay the first black woman in
the
seven she has real power maybe she can
even find Annabeth Marie has to choose
whether she wants to play by the vot
rules or keep digging into things and
attempt to try try to be the real hero
Andre Emma Jordan and Marie all get
texts from Kate telling them to come to
shett Andre ignores it opting to stay at
his dad's bedside at vot Tower but the
rest of the gang plus Sam do what Kate
asks and they arrive to find that Kate
has seemingly stuck with their original
plan and push Shetty to reveal the truth
to all of them shett gives us a ton of
information here each a bit more
fascinating than the last gulin is a
front Thomas gulin was a behavioral
scientist who built it not so soups
could go there to study but so that they
could study soups to find out their
weaknesses what makes them tick and how
to control trol them your subjects not
human we're better than humans damn it
Sam I am not liking his heel turn we
thought we knew you buddy I was just
hoping Emma would finally find a nice
boyfriend now in the comics gulan has a
super dark storyline that involves kids
and well talk about stranger danger we
saw a portrait earlier in Dean shed's
office that might have been Thomas gulin
but it's never identified Shetty tells
them that she wants the virus to kill
all soups because homelander took down
the plane that her family was on she
says that they all leave a path of
Destruction behind them and honestly she
ain't wrong her last assignment for Kate
was to kill everyone in the woods Kate
didn't do it but she also has an
interesting turn here she says that they
all want to wipe them off the face of
the Earth and so they have to strike
first starting with shett it kind of
seems like both Kate and Sam have been
radicalized Kate tells Shetty that it's
time and Shetty slits her own throat
Kate also pushes Marie not to help heal
her with her blood Powers Marie has
several flashbacks to her own mother
dying and they remark ly similar way to
Shetty and Kate tells her that she's so
sorry that she has to relive this as
Shetty bleeds to death on the floor we
cut to cardosa handing off the virus to
Newman and he definitely thinks he's the
good guy in this scenario as opposed to
the monster who's been killing kids he
uses the term compassionate control when
it comes to the soups and again I just
love that he has no idea that he is
saying this to a soup Newman hands him a
business card and tells him that he and
his family will be safe and witness
protection and we get this amazing
moment where as Newman walks away
cardosa looks down at the card and sees
that it is blank for his nose starts
bleeding and his head is popped like a
grape RP dude I kind of deserve this
Newman flicks a bit of cardosa off her
hand and then drives away and we end on
the y y Heads Will Roll playing over the
credits so a couple major questions here
what is Newman going to do with a virus
now that she has it the smartest thing
for her to do would be to destroy it
especially since we saw her giving
compound V to her daughter on the boys
which means any virus could potentially
kill her as well but knowing Newman and
knowing that she was raised by Stan
Edgar who always has a contingency plan
I think she's going to keep it just in
case it's not Airborne yet so she could
potentially use a version against
homelander if he ever decides to come
after her I also have to wonder what was
in that folder that cardosa left on
shed's desk if it was information about
the virus like how to create it then
it's definitely going to be a dangling
thread that could come back later the
biggest question I have though is was
that whole scene with Kate and the Gang
real okay so hear me out Kate had such
an Abrupt change from her scene right
before that with her head on shed's lap
saying that she believes that she loves
her too one scene later yelling at her
to shut up and ordering her to kill
herself I think that the last push
Shetty was talking about wasn't to kill
everyone in the woods because let's face
it she doesn't need Kate to do that she
could just have the guards do it instead
I think the last push was to show her
friends this bit of theater so that
Shetty could fake her death and Escape
Kate is more powerful now that the drugs
are wearing off so she might not even
need to physically touch people to
control them anymore which could explain
how she could make them see this Vision
remember that she told Marie I'm sorry
you have to relit this because she knew
Marie was thinking about her mother who
died in the same position the same way
Kate made her think shett did Shetty
miscalculated when she went to Grace
mallerie in the CIA she thought they'd
side with her to give her protection but
that's not how it played out she knows
that once vot finds out that she created
a virus that kills soups they're going
to send a whole bunch of soups after her
to kill her so her only shot at getting
out of this mess would be that if
everyone thinks she's dead so I think in
the season finale something is going to
go down on campus that causes a code red
we're going to see those St room bars
locked down as all hell breaks loose
with the soups fighting one another and
that in that chaos just like Jordan
caused a distraction earlier shed's
going to slip away since Andre wasn't
there to witness all this I think he's
going to say something that causes the
others to realize that something is off
and that Kate pushed them one last time
but I think she's also going to be gone
by then I think the finale will end with
a big Cameo from homelander called in to
claim the mess on campus and that season
two will start up with vot taking
control of and reopening the school
because you know they're great at
rebranding things let me know in the
comments below if you think this theory
about Kate really did help fake her
death or if she really did just force
Shetty to kill herself please subscribe
to all three channels on the new
rockstars Network and support us by
grabing some merch at nerd rot. shop big
thanks to genieo for writing this
breakdown follow me at eaos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
bye